you may play most of your video games as
a six-foot hulking behemoth of a month
but there are plenty of games that put
you in the shoes of female protagonists
space warriors journalists explorers
military commanders and zombie
apocalypse survivors are all acceptable
career paths in video games but
regardless of their job career of a
journey that they are on here is our
list of the top 10 female characters in
video games
now why are we left every day
number 10 Jill Valentine the Resident
Evil franchise
let's start off with my beloved Jill
Valentine from residency so Jill was the
main protagonist emergent evil one three
unravel Asian and also save Christmas
and evil five as a member of the stars
Alpha Team she has the firearm knowledge
and isn't afraid to shoot when the time
calls for it he's a martial artist with
more agility than a gymnastics team and
above all she has a half of gold
regularly going out of her way to save
the alpha males of the group she is the
deliver of kick-ass one-liners never
change Jill I love you
[Music]
number nine space Connors mirrors edge
mirror's edge took the skill of
freerunning and made it into a game not
only that they created a character like
norther you play as base Connors and
follow the tail of this athletic and
relatively normal young lady who was
known as a runner in the rebel ranking
only language there's something about
the mystique of faith as she fights a
corrupted system in the hopes of
obtaining justice for her wrongly
incarcerated sister the minimalist world
she lives in matches her attire and
attitude as she is forecast determined
and relentless best Connors may be the
first of a new generation of female
protagonists I'm going to send a clear
message to Kruger and you what this
should be too long ago number a shell
from the bottom staring about it's all
this just subject to destroy up try to
land on her now although portal was set
in first person the lady behind the
portal gun is chell personal story
remains a mystery and her inability to
talk really dense her likability but
this orange jump suit wearing test
subject for Aperture Science wasn't
willing to be just another failed
experiment she takes the fight to GLaDOS
a murderous artificial intelligence who
probably could be on this list herself
if she wasn't a machine that is called
shell takes her abuse regularly and
never react you are a horrible person
that's my pen a horrible person
we weren't even testing for that she is
simply focused on her goals surviving an
escaping I think in our differences
behind us for science you monster
number seven Noriko I'm in the cells and
you can see why you should hear me
Nariko is a sword-wielding heroin from
ps3 classic heavenly sod
although she was born on her time of
warriors she was shunned because she was
a woman the mockery she was stood made
her even stronger and she ultimately
became the survey of the entire world
what a way to make those haters eat
their words there was a downside to as
the sword she uses grunts mythical power
but ultimately kills whoever uses it in
battle
oh no Rico we have so little time
together and it still hurts that we
never saw a sequel to this game topped
out hey Paris Kai and I will I swear not
econ number six Clementine The Walking
Dead and there was that being in the
batter who tried to get me burger I was
scared
Telltale's The Walking Dead series was
originally about reluctant here only
with only the last segment of the game
being played as Clementine but for those
few short minutes she became our world
if you didn't know The Walking Dead is
set around the undead and how they're
devouring the earth with little
survivors to stop them
well Clementine returned as the main
protagonist in series 2 and our maternal
and paternal instincts kicked in again
as she went from innocent child to
full-blown apocalyptic butter the beauty
about this game is that we follow
Clementine we feel her pain we go
through everything that she goes through
and I would personally love it if there
was a crossover and she appeared in The
Walking Dead TV series but I highly
doubt that let's move on number 5 Lara
Croft Tomb Raider throughout history the
boulder of death my godfather you could
not have a list of iconic female
characters without Lara Croc she may
have started out with a sex symbol and I
can't deny finding the naked Lara patch
when I was a young man Dennis thank you
soon enough but she changed she
developed into modern polygonal boobs
and a battling pseudo British accent the
series reboot in 2013 showed us a
protagonist who had to survive her
environment she had to overcome the
obstacles and the numerous enemies she
became a character to be invested in and
a true icon what a difference from 1996
for some govern secret of the world is
the only way to live number 4
Julie sweet fighter
streetfighter was a sweaty testosterone
fight fest which continues to this day
oversized muscular men fighting small
oversized muscular men made my scrawny
muscles feel emasculated to say the
least
luckily there was a Honda to make me
feel better anyway I'm getting
sidetracked the first ever female
fighter came in the shape of tiny keep a
wearing chun-li with thighs a
professional bodybuilder what was proud
of chun-li not only fought in the street
fighter tournament but had a storyline
far better than many others in the
series she is an Interpol officer
relentlessly seeking revenge for her
father's death who died at the hands of
and bison at 5 foot 5 you wouldn't think
she had much of a chance but she became
one of the biggest names in street
fighter franchise and that's devastating
bloody kick combo called me to throw my
pad against the wall multiple times
sorry mum number three Samus Aran
Metroid
another undeniable female protagonist is
sama Saran from the Metroid series this
bounty hunter
protects the galaxy from space pirates
and although that sounds pretty lame in
this day and age that was mind-blowing
in 1986 the beauty of this entry was the
way she was revealed back in the 80s a
female hero was pretty much unheard of
so the makers of Metroid wanted to use
that single-mindedness and the success
of the character Ripley and alien to
shock gamers once they finish Metroid an
ex-soldier an intergalactic bounty
hunter Samus was always seen in hulking
exoskeleton armor traversing the galaxy
which made learning her gender at the
end of the game even more noteworthy
ever since Samus has become a symbol for
strong female protagonists and an
inspiration to women in the gaming
industry Samus Aran continues to this
day blowing up planets and keeping us
all safe number 2 a lie horizon zero
dawn
[Music]
horizon zero dawn places you in the
tanned leather boots of airline in a
futuristic world covered in mechanical
dinosaurs
I won't even attempt to explain that one
but wow this game is brilliant after
being expelled from her tribe as a
newborn baby and continuously being
shunned as a child she'd be forgiven for
becoming a horrible human being with
many issues to control well that's not
the case for our airline she puts
humanity first and helps the people that
once rejected her she'd easily win a
gold medal in the Olympic archery if
that was still a thing in a thousand
years and first fear work is second to
none technically a mastermind and an
efficient killer to a light horizon must
be returning for a sequel soon number 1
Ellie The Last of Us The Last of Us
changed storytelling in video games by
creating a surrogate father and daughter
relationship in a zombie field post
apocalypse environment playing as Joel
your feelings towards Ellie go from an
annoying child to all my word
you are my daughter but it wasn't until
jaw becomes unplayable and we still L
issues instead armed with a makeshift
bow and on envy of all odds early
survives and even prospers as a lead
character
as we know the Last of Us is really
intended and it's all about survival in
a game like this it's very easy for a
character to be surpassed by their
surroundings yet Ellie won over all
gamers due to the heart of this strong
character and the resourcefulness of a
fourteen-year-old girl surviving some
horrific circumstances her character her
wits her ability to fight for a Cause
made her the greatest female character
in videogame history she doesn't have
the physical skill of Tinley or the
firepower of Samus Aran or even the
tactical prowess of Chell the beauty of
this character is how real she is she is
the girl that you walk past in the
street she is that a 19 age with
terrible yet witty comebacks and
frightening mood swing above all else
she's an ordinary person putting
extraordinary circumstances and that's
why she tops this list what do you think
do you agree with me does Ellie deserve
to be at the top of this list or would
you put one of the hundreds of female
kick-ass protagonists that I have missed
off this list at the top please let me
know your thoughts below
I'll do a favor please click like a mid
even subscribe we want to reach more
people and to do that we need your help
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade I'll
see you next time
you